speaking of me too we talked about this
a little yesterday Alyssa Milano sent
out a tweet which launched this huge
social media campaign it's all over
Facebook and Twitter she said and this
is in response to the Harvey Weinstein
scandal it turns out he raped like every
aspiring actress in all of Hollywood and
this is a widespread problem in
Hollywood for a very long time now it's
all coming to light people are talking
about the horrific incidents that have
happened to them and she tweeted out and
said if you've been sexually harassed or
assaulted write me too is replied to
this tweet there's the problem this
there are a few problems with this
slacktivism with this hashtag activism
but the first is in her launching it she
says if you've been sexually assaulted
or harassed those are categorically
different things those are categorically
different they're both bad we should
stop both I suppose one is a is a
heinous crime one is assaulting
somebody's soul as well as their body
violating their Liberty and the other is
being rude and untoward and you know
maybe the guy at the office winks at his
secretary
that's all terrible - quite different
than rape and to conflate those two is
offensive and disrespectful toward the
victims of actual rape now a men are
virtue signaling back because that's how
the internet works with the hashtags
hashtag I will and hashtag how I will
change so here are just a few of them
hashtag I will promote women's voices
believe survivors and work to end rape
culture and purity culture two sides of
the same patriarchal coin how I will
change I will listen to women more
closely seeking to understand before
seeking to be understood then if it
helps I will act I will listen more
learn more acknowledge more in support
more I'm willing to have more courageous
conversations or use those courageous
words how courageous how I will change
means acknowledging my own capacity for
harmful behavior and taking
responsibility for unlearning that
toxicity I don't really take issue with
the premise here that man can be dogs
and they should behave themselves I take
issue with the supposed
prai's the shock the earnestness of the
tweeters I think it's mostly feigned I
think it's fake but some might be real
because these people are utopians and
they think that mankind can be perfected
with just a few more regulations a
little less freedom a little more effort
that isn't going to happen and living in
delusion will help nobody
so let's dispel some of the delusion
around this we begin with the courageous
conversations what is courageous about
echoing the dominant cultural meme what
is courageous about saying you're always
right I'm always wrong whatever the left
tells us is true even if the statistics
are spurious that's true I'll believe
anything
there isn't a rape culture in the United
States that was one of the allegations
there was a rape culture there is no
rape culture in the United States rape
happens because we're fallen people and
crime happens and murder happens and
awful things happen and will always
happen because we're not going back to
the Garden of Eden this isn't an earthly
paradise and human nature isn't
perfectible that's going to happen but
you know the rape culture is this
Pakistan that's a rape a culture that
institutionalizes and through its own
cultural mores creates venues in which
rape is approved of that is a rape
culture there is no approval of rape in
the United States the to tweet a
trending hashtag alleging rape culture
undermines the rape culture right it
undermines your own claim it's a
defeater for your ridiculous argument
the the hashtags too are empty virtue
signaling it is saccharine it is it is a
it's slacktivism that accomplishes
nothing it reminds me of I don't know if
people remember this Kony 2012 did you
remember in 2011 or 2012 there is this I
remember Michael do you remember this it
was everywhere Kony 2012 he was some
warlord in Uganda and some filmmaker
said we're gonna stop Kony this year and
then every little dummy on Twitter and
Facebook posted about it and they felt
they were doing something they felt they
were accomplishing something they
accomplished nothing he's still at large
it's it is a useless it is to make
yourself feel good to give the
impression of doing something it I've
heard this described about smoking
cigars and I will acknowledge it the
nice thing about smoking is you feel
like you're due
something but you're really just sitting
down and not doing anything that's
slacktivism Michelle Obama did this she
held up a sign when those girls were
kidnapped by Boko Haram in Nigeria the
sign said no joke hashtag
bringbackourgirls that's the Sun this is
the courageous piece of paper or hashtag
your husband is the President of the
United States if you want to bring back
the girls you can bring back the girls
now perhaps the issue isn't as simple as
all of that perhaps there are
geopolitics at play that complicate
things don't pretend that your hashtag
is doing anything it's accomplishing
absolutely nothing also don't tweet
about it if you're a guy don't tweet I
will I'm with you I these guys these
like fake feminists sensitive earnest
nice guys there are like the creepiest
guys around do not but they are creeps I
would not let my fiance near any of them
they are women do not believe them the
the feminist men protest too much
methinks
next if you've been raped go to the
police go to the police do not go to
your professor do not go to your
administrator on campus do not pass go
do not collect $200 it is a serious
crime it is possibly the most serious
crime if it has happened make sure that
it is prosecuted to the full extent of
the law
we have a system for prosecuting crimes
it's called the criminal justice system
it's not the sort of crime to be dealt
with by campus tribunals this leads into
another aspect though we have a criminal
justice system to protect the rights of
the accusers but also to protect the
rights of the accused so the people who
have had a crime committed against them
and also those of a accuse of doing it
these campus tribunals have been
absolutely demolishing the due process
rights of the accused in in countless
cases but a lot of the tweets that have
been coming with I will or I you know
this is what I will do
they say that we'll always believe the
people who allege that they have been
raped Hillary Clinton said this during
the campaign which is quite ironic
because she smeared the people who
alleged rape against her own husband
someone might ask why would anyone make
up a rape why would anyone
they've been raped if they haven't I
don't know it's pretty weird man but it
does happen in just the last eight years
there have been five instances five
major instances of this presumably many
others there was obviously the rolling
stone uva rape hoax this was a major
story in rolling stone a girl alleged
she had been gang-raped at a fraternity
it didn't happen the story absolutely
fell apart they had to retract the whole
thing at UC Santa Cruz a few years ago a
girl paid someone on Craigslist to beat
her up and then she alleged that she had
been raped that also fell apart in 2013
a University of Wyoming student posted a
rape threat against herself in a campus
Facebook group that also was uncovered
but not before it caused a lot of
anxiety to the campus community a lot of
other people 2009 a hospice Hofstra
student had consensual sex with five
guys at once her boyfriend found out and
said you look like you've just had sex
with a lot of guys and she said I've
been raped he said go to the police she
said no that I don't need to and then
they went to the police anyway they
arrested these guys they threw them in
jail only because there happened to be a
video of this event why don't want to
know what were these guys let off the
hook for it because it the video showed
that it was consensual but nevertheless
the allegation was made it could have
ruined these guys lives in 2013 a
University of Florida student falsely
claims she was raped in a parking lot
then she said it was false but intended
to show a greater truth so she it was a
complete lie but then it was the lie was
meant to serve the greater truth and
then later she admitted it's because her
parents were pressuring her to graduate
from college and she probably wasn't
going to do that conservative columnist
George Will was accused of not taking
rape seriously in a letter by four
Democratic senators because he made
these exact same points and he responded
in exactly the right way he said he said
he takes a sexual assault and rape much
more seriously than they do you know
some would prefer it if professors and
campus tribunals dealt with this crime
some would prefer it if judges juries
and executioner's dealt with it the the
we in the latter category are taking
this issue much more serious
and the people who are engaging in
frivolous slacktivism are doing nothing
but hurting a very serious issue